[Musique]
le djinn découpé entre la ces matières
premières de cette reconstruction
une pièce pensé par marion et sylvie
breton est créé avec d'aiguillon
courtois volontaire là on est vraiment
premier atelier
c'est une base de départ qui ont validé
c'est un petit peu d'habiller le
l'escalier de la mairie à guyancourt
celle aussi l'usure du temps c'est
malgré tout même si on n'en récupère
beaucoup actuellement c'est un certain
un objet de travail c'est un vêtement de
travail et
il est d'une texture intéressant d'une
texture qui s'usent d'une texture que
tout le monde porte
petits grands la pièce rejoindra le 9
mars l'exposition des gens courent à
l'hôtel de ville
si cette lustres majestueux imposant
trônant sur la mezzanine des pièces
uniques et différentes décline en tissus
et matériaux comme on travaille beaucoup
avec la notion de recyclage et de
retravailler la matière l'art transforme
et c'est une matière qui permet d d
des effets assez incroyable et un fini
les lustres pour nous c'est un objet à
la fois qu'ils n'étaient identifiables
comme c'est à la fois une sculpture un
objet décoratif
ça n'a aucune utilité monte et on l'aimé
bien et c'est un très beau volume ça
permet et c'est quelque chose qui parle
à tous évidente à gérer
illustre sa objet le bel objet par
excellence des cravates des boutons des
bobines de fil des pièces de la
manufacture bowe dernière entreprise
d'épingler française un thème par
lustres pour une plongée dans la petite
histoire du textile